any concerns from anyone right surgical
team captain for surgeon Jeremy
Granville Chapman and his team this
operation is the very definition of
routine we're going to repair the torn
tendon at the front which is one of his
deep layer of muscles called the rotator
cuff they've carried out more than a
thousand joint operations at Heatherwood
Hospital in under 10 months
it's patient pretty girl slipped in his
garden in August he landed awkwardly
tearing the tendons in his arm before
today he was one of more than seven
million people waiting for routine
Hospital treatments that waiting list
has grown by over a million in the last
year alone and while there's no doubt
that elective surgery hubs like this one
will have an impact
that impact will depend very much on
other factors like the workforce crisis
and the industrial action that's been
staged by health workers
this is a specialist planned care
facility they can do as many as 80 joint
Replacements a week and the hope is that
hospitals like this one will mean less
pressure is felt Across The Wider Health
Service we have now realized that winter
pressures are 12 months not just three
months which means the acute sites are
not going to be able to do planned
activity what they plan for so we got to
create more space is this going to be a
model for the future this is the model
we're already looking can we expand this
unit can we make two more thetas next
year to take the pressure off
the government has made reducing NHS
waiting lists one of its five priorities
for the year
and new surgical hubs like this one
might be the key to making it happen
but it is yet to reveal how it plans to
recruit and retain enough staff
announcement of a long-term Workforce
plan is positive what we need in that
Workforce plan is a plan for both
increasing the workforce how many
Workforce we need how you retain the
workforce and also how we fund all of
these extra staff
pradeep is now out of surgery and should
be home in just a couple of hours you
don't realize I mean how much you take
things for granted um with your mobility
and being able to move your
you know your arms how much it restricts
you
so yeah I'm glad
elective surgery but also life-changing
with Millions more waiting in line our
sister Josh is Sky News at Heatherwood
Hospital in ask us